To whom do these companies owe loyalty?
What does loyalty mean?
Well, it turns out that that was a rather naive concept anyway...
...as corporations always owe an obligation to themselves to get large and to get profitable.
In doing this, it tends to be more profitable to the extent it can make other people pay the bills...
...for its impact on society.
There's a terrible word that economists use for this; it's called "externalities".
An externality is the effect of a transaction between two individuals...
...on a third party who has not consented to or played any role in the carrying out of that transaction.
And there are real problems in that area, there's no doubt about it.
Running a business is a tough proposition.
There are costs to be minimized at every turn.
And at some point, the corporation says, "You know, let somebody else deal with that."
Let's let somebody else supply the military power to the Middle East to protect the oil and its source.
Let's let somebody else build the roads that we can drive these automobiles on.
Let's let somebody else have those problems.
And that is where externalities come from;...
...that notion of "let somebody else deal with that."
"I got all I can handle myself."
A corporation is an externalizing machine in the same way a shark is a killing machine.
Each one is designed in a very efficient way to accomplish particular objectives.
In the achievement of those objectives, there isn't any question of malevolence or of will.
The enterprise has within it and the shark has within it those characteristics that enable it to do...
...that for which it was designed.
So, the pressure is on the corporation to deliver results now...
...and to externalize any calls that this unweary or uncaring public will allow it to externalize.